Viren, die aggressiv machen, Pilze,
die das Denken beeinflussen und Würmer,
die sich bis in unser Gehirn fressen. Wie man
zum Zombie wird, das klären wir in dieser Folge.
Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Vor genau einem Jahr haben wir hier gemeinsam mit
Biologin und Neurowissenschaftlerin Stina geklärt,
dass Zombies eigentlich gar nicht so unrealistisch
sind. Zumindest wenn man sich ihr Verhalten
anschaut. Viele von Euch haben sich daraufhin
direkten einen zweiten Teil gewünscht. Denn eine
Frage ist ja noch offen. Was genau verwandelt
jetzt eigentlich Menschen in Zombie? Bevor wir
in dieses Sequel starten, sagt Ihr mir doch mal
was Euer Zombie-Favorit ist? Egal ob Serie,
Game oder Film – lasst mal einen Kommentar
dazu da. Und wenn Ihr dabei seid, freue ich
mich natürlich, wenn Ihr ein Abo dalasst.
Lasst uns zu Beginn einen kleinen Überblick
verschaffen, denn Zombies begegnen uns jetzt
schon seit über 80 Jahren in Filmen und Serien.
Da hat sich also einiges an Ursachen für die
Apokalypse angesammelt. Und die besten davon
kann uns natürlich nur einer zusammenfassen,
nämlich unser liebster Filmexperte vom
Kanal Cinema Strikes Back… Hi Alper!
Hi, Jack! Zombies sind ein richtiges Phänomen
der Popkultur. Und mit dem Hype wurden auch die
Erklärungen immer abstruser. Wie werden Menschen
eigentlich zu Zombies? In „Night of the Living
Dead“ ist es zum Beispiel Weltraumstrahlung.
In „Planet Terror“ sind es chemische Waffen,
aber ganz früher, im ersten Zombiefilm überhaupt
„White Zombie“ war es Voodoo-Zauber. Auch
bei „Ash vs Evil Dead“ der Serienneuauflage von
„Tanz der Teufel“ ist es Magie. Die beliebteste
Erklärung ist aber noch immer das gefährliche
Zombie-Virus. In „Resident Evil“ zum Beispiel wird
das Virus als Biowaffe von der Umbrella
Corporation entwickelt. In „28 Days later“
bricht es aus einem Forschungslabor aus, indem mit
Affen experimentiert wurde. In „World War Z“ wird
am Ende sogar ein zweites Virus eingesetzt, um
die Menschen für Zombies unsichtbar zu machen.
Danke Alper! Und ich sage mal so. Eine globale
Seuche, die sich extrem schnell ausbreitet und
für chaotische Zustände sorgt, haben ja nun
alle leider miterlebt und ich sogar am eigenen
Leib. Ich habe mir tatsächlich zwei Wochen vor
diesem Dreh, nach anderthalb Jahren noch Corona
eingefangen. Jetzt ist zum Glück alles wieder
safe aber Fakt ist, diese Ansteckungsszenarien,
die wir in den Filmen präsentiert bekommen, die
finden wir jetzt schon im echten Leben wieder.
Das heißt die eigentliche Frage ist, ob es
ein Virus geben kann, dass uns diese typischen
Zombie-Eigenschaften gibt? Das klären wir jetzt
mit der Gehirnexpertin dieses Formates… Hi Stina!
Moin!
Wir haben ja letztes Jahr in der Folge mit Dir
gelernt, dass diese typischen Zombie-Eigenschaft
durch Veränderungen und Schäden in ganz bestimmten
Gehirnarealen entstehen. Das heißt, für
einen Zombie-Virus braucht man einen Virus,
dass das Gehirn angreift. Gibt es sowas?
Ja. Es gibt auf jeden Fall einige Viren,
die das Gehirn und auch unser Nervensystem
angreifen können. Zum Beispiel das Rabies
Virus. Das löst Tollwut aus und es bedient
auch einige unserer Zombie Kriterien. Zum
Beispiel kann es im Verlauf einer Krankheit zu
Angstzuständen, aggressivem Verhalten und anderen
Fehlfunktionen des Gehirns führen. Es wird
auch noch über Speichel übertragen und führt
zu einer vermehrten Speichelbildung. Das passt
mit den Bissen richtig gut zu unseren Zombies.
Ein Zombie-Virus müsste so ähnlich
funktionieren. Aber gerade gegen
Tollwut gibt es ja schon eine Impfung.
Also Deutschland ist seit 2008 quasi
komplett tollwutfrei. Und dann gibt es noch einen
weiteren Faktor, der ein Problem ist. Das ist die
Inkubationszeit. Das kann bei Tollwut von wenigen
Tagen bis hin sogar zu mehreren Jahren andauern,
dass die Infektion durchbricht. Je nachdem, wo
du gebissen wurdest und wie gut ein Immunsystem
ist. Und dann gibt es noch ein weiteres
Problem: Tollwut ist tödlich. Das heißt,
innerhalb von einer Woche kann
Tollwut unbehandelt zum Tod führen
Passt alles nicht so ganz. Und das heißt ja
dann auch, ich könnte die Apokalypse aussitzen,
indem ich mich in einem Bunker
einschließe und einfach warte,
bis nach ein paar Wochen alle Zombies tot sind.
Richtig. Und wenn du wirklich so eine rasante
Ausbreitung von apokalyptischem Ausmaß
haben möchtest, dann müsste sich das Virus
eigentlich eher über die Luft verbreiten - wie zum
Beispiel bei Grippeviren oder auch Coronaviren.
Das heißt, wir bräuchten verschiedene Viren
Eigenschaften in einem Virus. Also wir
müssten uns irgendwas so Baukasten
mäßig zusammenstellen. Geht sowas?
Ja. Die Zeitung National Geographic hat
dazu mal ein bisschen rumgesponnen und
eine Virologin befragt. Und die hat gesagt, dass
unter Laborbedingungen und mit Techniken wie zum
Beispiel Genomchirurgie, dass es eventuell möglich
wäre, so ein Virus zusammenzubauen. Aber das würde
einen enormen technischen und finanziellen
Aufwand bedeuten. Und ohne konkreten Nutzen
würde das eigentlich niemand durchführen.
Und dass es auf natürlichem Wege passiert,
hält die Virologin für ausgeschlossen.
Das heißt für dieses Szenario bräuchten
wir eine „Real Life Umbrella-Corporation“, die
im Labor ein genetisch verändertes Tollwutvirus
zusammenkocht, das nicht auf unsere Impfung
anspringt, viel schneller Symptome auslöst,
nicht tödlich ist und sich über die Luft
ausbreitet, um die Ansteckungsrate zu erhöhen.
Das klingt jetzt nicht besonders realistisch.
Okay, aber was ist, wenn sich das
Virus gar nicht erst ausbreiten muss und auch
schon gut mit dem menschlichen Körper klarkommt?
So wie das bei „The Walking Dead“ der Fall ist?
Also da haben alle Menschen das Zombie-Virus
schon in sich. Und es wird erst dann aktiv, wenn
die Menschen sterben oder gebissen werden. Und so
ein schlummern im Körper gibt es ja im echten
Leben, nämlich beim Herpes-Virus. Ein Großteil
der Menschheit trägt die schon in sich. In
Deutschland haben 90% der Bevölkerung die
Viren für Lippenherpes schon im Körper.
Und wenn die einmal da sind, bleiben die
auch ein Leben lang da. Die lösen dann auch
erstmal keine Krankheiten aus, solange das
Immunsystem gut funktioniert und man gesund ist.
Und ich persönlich habe auch das schon erlebt.
Ich hatte mal längerfristig mit einer Krankheit zu
tun, da war mein Körper also beschäftigt. Und dann
hatten die Viren frei Bahn und ich habe diese
richtig ekligen Lippenbläschen bekommt. Wenn
mich jetzt ein Zombie beißt, dann ist ja mein
Körper auch geschwächt und unter Stress. Und
durch den Biss könnten ja auch noch andere Keime
reinkommen. Also mein Immunsystem wäre wieder
belastet. Das heißt, das wäre doch eigentlich
ein Reallife Pendant für ein schlummerndes Virus.
Prinzipiell ja. Wir kennen Herpes hauptsächlich
aus dem Gesicht, aber in einzelnen Fällen kann
das Virus sogar bis ins Gehirn vordringen.
Eklig aber für uns perfekt! Es muss ja dahin!
Ja genau. Ich kann Dir, dass auch mal zeigen. Ich
habe hier einen Scan von einem Patienten, da ist
das Virus wirklich bis ins Gehirn vorgedrungen.
Und zwar hier an den Seiten. Und wenn diese
Schäden eigentlich eher so in den präfrontalen
Bereich, also zum Beispiel hier oben, vordringen
würden, dann könnte ich mir schon vorstellen,
dass so ein Mensch zombie-ähnliche Züge annimmt.
Weil dann könnten wir Einschränkungen in
der Impulskontrolle, aber auch gesteigertes
aggressives Verhalten erwarten. Es gibt
aber ein ganz großes Problem für die gesamte
Virustheorie. Für unsere Zombie Verhaltensweisen
bräuchten wir ja ganz spezifische Schäden in ganz
bestimmten Hirnarealen. Und so wie sich
die Viren ausbreiten, eher unspezifisch,
wäre es eher unwahrscheinlich, dass das Ganze
bei allen Menschen immer gleich passiert.
Das heißt Zombie-Viren müssten sehr
viel maßgeschneiderter agieren,
als sie das jetzt auf natürliche Weise tun.
Genau. Und wir haben eigentlich auch das
gleiche Problem bei Bakterien. Ich habe da
noch mal einen Scan mitgebracht und zwar
hat hier bei einem Patienten eine
bakterielle Hirnhautentzündung ein
Viertel des gesamten Gehirns weggefressen,
also wirklich einen riesengroßen Teil. Das
heißt auch bei Bakterien wäre der Schaden
am Ende eher global und nicht so spezifisch.
Das ist eine harte Abfuhr fürs Genre.
Also Bakterien sind es nicht und Viren,
der Zombie-Standard schlechthin, sind auch raus!
Fiese Mikroben haben wir jetzt also abgewählt. Das
heißt, wir brauchen einen neuen Vorschlag. Alper
sag mal, was die Filmwelt noch so zu bieten hat.
Wenn es um die Verwandlung von Menschen in
gruselige Kreaturen geht, dann greift Hollywood
gerne auf Parasiten zurück. Zugegeben, dass es vor
allem ein beliebtes Weltraum Ding. Man denke nur
an „Alien“ und wie ein Xenomorph aus dem Brustkorb
von Kane herausbricht. Es gibt aber auch einen
Film, der Weltraum und Zombie Elemente miteinander
verbinde. Das ist das Regiedebüt von James Gang:
„Sliver“. Dort sind es wurmartige Aliens die
eine Kleinstadt befallen und die Menschen
übernehmen. Nach und nach werden fast alle
Bewohner und Bewohnerinnen infiziert. Auch
in der Vampir-Zombie-Serie „The Strain“ von
Guillermo del Toro sind es kleine Würmer,
die ihre Opfer in blutrünstige Untote verwandeln.
Interessant wird es eigentlich immer genau dann,
wenn Zombiefilme alte Klischees aufbrechen.
Wurmzombies? Das wird jetzt aber ganz schön
absurd hier. Denkt Ihr vielleicht! Aber
in diesem ziemlich coolen Buch von zwei
amerikanischen Wissenschaftlern gibt es
genau dafür ein sehr gutes Beispiel aus
der Natur. Nämlich aus dem Tierreich.
Da gibt es eine Gruppe von Parasiten,
Kratzbäume heißen die, und die können das
Nervensystem anderer Tiere beeinflussen
und damit am Ende deren Verhalten steuern. Sie
also quasi in willenlose Zombies verwandeln. Die
befallen zum Beispiel kleine Krebstiere und graben
sich von außen bis in deren Nervensystem vor,
wo sie dann den Impuls auslösen, Richtung Licht
zu schwimmen. Diese Krebstiere sind nämlich
eigentlich lichtscheu, aber der Parasit
dreht ihnen dieses Verhalten komplett um.
Die Krebstiere schwimmen dann also in höhere
Wasserschichten, werden dann von Fischen gefressen
und das ist der Gag daran. Denn genau da möchte
der Parasit hin - in den Verdauungstrakt eines
Fisches, weil er sich nur dort vermehren
kann. Die Natur ist also irre kreativ,
wenn es ums fortpflanzen geht.
Stina sag mit bitte,
dass es das nur bei Tieren gibt!
Tut mir leid aber ich muss Dir wirklich
sagen, dass es gibt Gehirnwürmer auch beim
Menschen gibt. Es gibt eine Infektion die
nennt sich Neurozystizerkose und die kommt vom
Schweinebandwurm. Wenn Menschen also Eier, zum
Beispiel durch kontaminiertes Fleisch aufnehmen,
können die Larven, die sich daraus entwickeln,
sogar über die großen Blutgefäße bis ins
Gehirn vordringen. Und das können dann
sogar gleich mehrere Larven sein. Bei einem
Patienten hat man bis zu 30 davon gefunden.
30 Stück? Das ist super
eklig. Und was machen die da?
Die können sich dann quasi an den Wänden
von Blutgefäßen einnisten und da kleine
Verkapselung bilden. Die können ein bis
zwei Zentimeter groß sein und von dort aus
dann Nährstoffe aus der Blutversorgung klauen.
Das klingt super ekelhaft und auch ziemlich groß
eigentlich. Aber es muss nicht unbedingt
problematisch sein. Nur zum Beispiel,
wenn das Ganze zu Entzündungen führt
oder wenn die Kapseln größer werden.
Die können dann wie ein kleiner Tumor
auf das Hirngewebe drücken. Und dann
kann es zu Problemen kommen, wie zum
Beispiel Verhaltensauffälligkeiten,
Sprachstörungen, aber auch Psychosen.
Das passt dann ganz gut, denn Hirnschäden,
Sprachstörungen und Verhaltensänderung bringt uns
alles ein ganz gutes Stück in Richtung Zombies.
Und auch, dass mit dieser Anzahl haut
hin. Denn bei „The Strain“ sehen wir,
wie eine ganze Reihe von Würmern einen einzelnen
Wirt befallen kann. Also das haut hin Dann müssen
wir uns nur noch Gedanken über die Ausbreitung
machen. Bei „Sliver“ ist es so, dass die Parasiten
sich eigenständig fortbewegen und superschnell
die gesamte Stadt infizieren. Nur eine Handvoll
Bewohner bleibt da verschont und auch bei „The
Strain“ schmeißen sich diese Würmer quasi gierig
auf die Köpfe ihrer Opfer drauf. Stina jetzt
sind die bei uns natürlich wesentlich kleiner.
Aber könnten die so eine Epidemie auslösen?
Nein. Die Neurozystizerkose überträgt sich über
die Larven aus dem Bandwurmeiern und die können
sich von alleine gar nicht fortbewegen. Das heißt,
die müssen erst einmal aufgenommen werden,
zum Beispiel durch verunreinigtes Fleisch.
Das ist häufig ein Problem von mangelnder Hygiene,
verbunden mit Armut. In Deutschland sind Fälle
allerdings super selten. Es gab aber einmal den
Fall eines 60-jährigen Landwirtes. Der konnte
sich durch die Würmer immer weniger merken und hat
auch nach einer Weile eine Stand- und Gang-Ataxie
entwickelt. Das heißt, er konnte nicht mehr sicher
stehen und ist auch er so breitbeinig gegangen.
Und da sind wir dann wieder bei dem Zombie-Gang,
über den wir letztes Mal schon gesprochen hatten.
Stimmt, würde sehr gut passen. Aber
wenn es bei uns super selten ist,
wie hat er sich die Krankheit denn eingefangen?
Er hat die Würmer dadurch bekommen, dass er über
mehrere Jahre jeden Tag rohes Fleisch zu sich
genommen hat. Und dass das nicht gesund ist
kann man sich ja eigentlich denken. Das zeigt
aber wieder, dass eine rasante Ausbreitung,
wie in einer Zombie-Apokalypse, so eigentlich
eher nicht möglich ist. Es sei denn,
Mett wird jetzt die neue Trenddiät. Und wir haben
wieder ein klassisches Problem, dass die Schäden
durch die Larven wieder eher unspezifisch
sind, weil die ja immer da stattfinden,
wo die Larven sich eben gerade aufhalten.
Das heißt, Real Life Horror durch Gehirnwürmer,
ja die gibt es, aber Auslöser für
die Zombie-Apokalypse sind die nicht.
Irgendwie wird es langsam eng mit einer handfesten
Zombie-Apokalypse, was total schade ist, denn ich
wäre voll bereit für den Kampf ums Überleben. Wie
sieht es bei Euch aus? Wenn morgen die Untoten
vor der Tür stehen, würdet Ihr dann eher abhauen
und Euch ein Versteck suchen? Oder würdet Ihr zu
den Waffen gehen und kämpfen? Schreibt mir das
mal in die Kommentare. Und lasst uns jetzt mal
noch ein Szenario finden, denn ich will, dass
das hier funktioniert. Und die Kreativität der
Horror-Leute sollten wir auch nicht unterschätzen.
Alper, Du hast doch bestimmt noch was für uns!
Viel Mühe haben sich die Menschen von „The Last
of us“ gegeben, der Spielereihe. Aktuell laufen
in Kanada sogar die Dreharbeiten zu der Serie,
die auf der Reihe basieren soll. Hier ist es ein
parasitärer Pilz, der Menschen in zombieartige
Wesen verwandelt. Diese Verwandlung passiert,
wenn man die Spuren des Pilzes einatmete oder wenn
man von einer bereits infizierten Person gebissen
wird. Der Pilz wächst dann zum Beispiel aus dem
Kopf, sodass die Zombies irgendwann erblinden. Ab
einem gewissen Stadium können sich die Zombies
sogar nur noch über ihr Gehör orientieren.
Richtig fies darin sind die sogenannten „Blowter“.
Bei ihnen sind die Pilzwucherungen schon zu einer
Rüstung geworden. Bei einem Angriff können sie
sogar Sporen-Bomben auf ihre Gegner schleudern und
damit mehrere Menschen gleichzeitig infizieren.
Dass sie ziemlich krass aus. Aber bei dem Game
wurde nicht nur optisch aufs Detail geachtet,
sondern tatsächlich auch wissenschaftlich. Denn
der Pilz aus dem Spiel ist nicht ausgedacht.
Die Gattung Cordyzeps gibt es wirklich. Und in
biologischen Studien, die sich mit dem Pilz
befassen, taucht dann auch immer wieder das
Wort Zombismus auf. Denn der Pilz ist bekannt
dafür, das Denken von Insekten zu kapern und
in den Regenwäldern auf der Erde passiert
das tatsächlich jeden Tag, und zwar so:
Die Sporen des Pilzes landen zum Beispiel auf
einer Ameise, dringen dann in den Körper ein und
infizieren nach und nach das Ameisengehirn
und verändern das Verhalten der Ameise.
Der Pilz bringt die Ameise nämlich dazu, auf eine
Pflanze zu klettern, so ungefähr 25 Zentimeter
über dem Boden, was die normalerweise nicht
machen, weil sie dort halt Fressfeinden ausgesetzt
sind. Aber der Pilz hat die Kontrolle über das
Verhalten und bringt die Ameise dann noch dazu,
sich in dieser Pflanze festzubeißen. Die kommt
also nicht mehr von der Stelle. Und dann tötet
der Pilz die Ameise, ernährt sich von ihrem
Körper und zu allem Übel wächst ihr dann auch
noch aus dem Kopf heraus ein riesiger, langer
Stil. Und über diesen Stil verbreitet der Pilz
dann neue Sporen und kann so im schlimmsten
Fall die gesamte Ameisenkolonie infizieren.
Das heißt, der Zombie Mechanismus von „The Last
of us“ ist tatsächlich von der Natur abgeschaut
und nicht nur dieser Mechanismus, sondern auch
diese ganzen Auswüchse und Wucherungen, die wir
im Game bei den Menschen sehen. Denn der Pilz
kann tatsächlich aus dem gesamten Insektenkörper
herauswachsen. Und das betrifft nicht nur
Ameisen. Das gibt es auch bei Spinnen, Motten,
Heuschrecken und anderen Arten. Es gibt Hunderte
verschiedene Cordyzeps-Varianten, die auf ganz
spezielle Insekten spezialisiert sind. Auch wenn
nicht jeder Cordyzepspilz, deren Gehirn kapert,
sondern teilweise nur in und von denen lebt.
Interessant ist jetzt aber, dass es dokumentierte
Fälle gibt, bei denen der Cordyzepspilz eine
bewusstseinsverändernde Wirkung sogar beim
Menschen hatte. 1954 gab es das in einer kleinen
Stadt in Frankreich. Da war eine Ladung Getreide
mit dem Pilz befallen und dadurch ist eine gesamte
Stadt extrem verhaltensauffällig geworden. Ein
kleines zwölfjähriges Mädchen hat dort sogar
versucht, mit einem Küchenmesser ihre Mutter
umzubringen. Also voll der Zombi-Ragemodus.
Das war nur wegen des Pilzes?
Also das lag eigentlich an diesen Substanzen,
die der Pilz absondert. Die können nämlich
unsere Wahrnehmung, unser Denken, Fühlen und
Handeln beeinflussen. Sehr gut dokumentiert
ist das aber für einen anderen Pilz, der schon
jahrhundertelang zu Epidemien mit tausenden
Infizierten geführt hat: Mutterkorn.
Mutterkorn ist ein parasitärer Pilz,
der auf Roggen wächst und schon seit dem frühen
Mittelalter zu massenhaften Vergiftungen geführt
hat, die auch schwere körperliche Schäden haben
konnten, aber auch zu Wahnvorstellungen und
Verwirrtheitszuständen geführt haben. Heute weiß
man, dass man solche Verunreinigungen im Getreide
vermeiden muss, auch wenn die Stoffe
aus dem Mutterkorn sogar noch viele
positive Anwendungen in der Medizin haben können.
Wollen wir das zusammenfassen kann man ja sagen,
dass Pilze in gewisser Weise unser
Verhalten verändern und sich über diese
Sporen verbreiten. Das ist relativ plausibel.
Damit kann man recht einfach infiziert werden.
Absolut. Aber das diese Sporen uns
in Zombie-Monster verwandeln passt
natürlich super gut in ein Horror-Game, aber
es ist eigentlich nicht so plausibel. Aber
wenn ich mich für eine Variante entscheiden
müsste, dann wäre es auf jeden Fall der Pilz.
Und dazu kommt ja noch, wenn wir uns jetzt
zu Pilzerkrankungen allgemein anschauen,
die sind auf jeden Fall eine tödliche Bedrohung.
Jedes Jahr sterben über 1,5 Millionen Menschen
weltweit an Pilzerkrankungen. Dass es
immerhin viermal mehr als an Malaria.
Stina vielen Dank fürs Erklären!
Immer wieder gerne und immer schön
aufpassen, wenn Euch jemand anhustet
oder mit Sporen bewerfen möchte!
Ja, dann machen wir so hier! Und ich sage auch
danke an Alper vom Kanal Cinema Strikes Back.
Flitzt mal zu dem rüber und lasst ein bisschen
Liebe von uns da. Und wenn euch das Thema
Horror im Allgemeinen interessiert, dann habe
ich doch einen Tipp für Euch. Hört euch mal den
Podcast meine MDR WISSEN- Kollegin Daniela
Schmitt an. Die hat sich nämlich gefragt,
warum wir Menschen uns überhaupt gruseln
und hat das auch aktiv an sich getestet,
obwohl sie selbst eigentlich eher ein Angsthase
ist. Link dazu packe ich euch in die Infobox.
Natürlich können wir Euch mit so einer
Folge immer nur eine gewisse Auswahl
liefern. Aber eigentlich gibt es noch
eine ganze Menge andere spannende Sachen,
die mit in diese ganze Thematik reinfallen.
Zum Beispiel der Einzeller Toxoplasma gondii.
Der löst die Krankheit Toxoplasmose aus und
auch der kann menschliches Verhalten ändern,
indem er gewisse Prozesse im Gehirn beeinflusst.
Menschen, die davon befallen sind, können zum
Beispiel risikofreudiger oder impulsiver werden
und auch ihre Reaktionszeit ist dann verlangsamt.
In einigen wissenschaftlichen Studien wird
er sogar in Verbindung mit Schizophrenie
gebracht. Dann gibt es dann noch Prionen. Das
sind eigentlich nur Proteine, die liegen aber
in so einer speziellen Struktur vor, dass
genau diese Struktur Krankheiten auslösen
kann. Bei Rindern zum Beispiel BSE, also den
Rinderwahn und beim Menschen das Pendant dazu,
die Creutzfeldt-Jakob-Krankheit.
Auch bei der kann es zu
Persönlichkeitsveränderungen kommen, zu physischen
Schäden, aber auch zu neurologischen Schäden,
weil diese Prionen eben fortschreitend das
Gehirn zerstören. Und am Ende spielt für mich
auch irgendwie dieses Wort Smombie in diese ganze
Betrachtung mit rein. Denn Menschen, die täglich
mehrere Stunden am Handy verbringen, die zeigen
nachweislich Veränderungen im Gehirn. Das muss
nichts Schlechtes sein, auch jeder, der ein neues
Instrument lernt, zeigt Veränderungen im Gehirn,
aber es gibt eben Studien die nahelegen, dass ein
vermehrter Handykonsum zu Konzentrationsproblemen
führen kann, zu Schlafstörungen und am Ende
auch zu so etwas wie einer richtigen Sucht.
Und das ist es am Ende ja auch, was diese
ganzen Zombiefilme transportieren wollen,
zumindest auf der Metaebene. Dass wir
Menschen in gewissen Situationen Sklaven
der äußeren Umstände sind, eine willenlose,
ferngesteuerte, homogene Masse, die am Ende
nur nach ihren Instinkten und Trieben handelt.
Ihr seht, da ist jede Menge Stoff für neue
Zombie-Folgen vorhanden. Und wenn Ihr nicht drauf
warten wollt, dann schaut doch jetzt schon mal in
die Infobox, denn da habe ich ganz viele spannende
Links zu dieser Thematik zusammengefasst.
Vielleicht habt Ihr aber auch eine ganz eigene
Zombie-Theorie. Dann schreibt die doch gern in
die Kommentare, lasst uns ein bisschen austauschen
und diskutieren und schreibt mir auch gern wieder
wie Ihr diese Folge fahndet. Am meisten freue ich
mich natürlich, wenn Ihr diesen Kanal abonniert
und unsere Glocke drückt. Dann können wir uns
nämlich bald wiedersehen. Ich freue mich drauf!
Von Zombies zu Orks geht es hier drüben bei
unseren Homies von Cinema Strikes Back. Die
hatten nämlich gerade Ringwochen und haben
jede Menge coole „Herr der Ringe“-Videos
veröffentlicht. Lasst doch mal ein paar
Grüße da. Und wenn Ihr Appetit bekommen habt,
hier ist unser eigenes „Herr der Ringe“-Video
und das zeigt Euch, wie man Lembasbrot backt.